this Penny isn't worth one cent it's
worth 10 billion dollars at least for
this video okay and it's going into the
treasury to be spent on an entire year
of
the Environmental Protection Agency
here's how much went to unemployment and
NASA
last year more than six trillion dollars
or 627 pennies were spent on different
programs but that required taking on
more than one trillion dollars in debt
let's go to the board to look at federal
spending including that debt and the
ways the U.S could borrow fewer pennies
but first where did all the pennies
spent in 2022 come from
here's how many came from revenue things
like individual income taxes and payroll
taxes and corporate taxes Congress is
responsible for both these totals they
set the tax rate and they authorized the
spending but since these don't match up
the treasury takes on debt to cover this
difference they do that by selling
securities like say a 20-year bond an
investor gives the treasury money and
the treasury would pay interest on that
every six months
they'll do that until the 20 years is
over and then the investor will get
their money back
but those interest payments add up that
is one of the expenses that people who
worry about the debt and the deficit
like to focus on the most or they see as
one of the biggest problems is how much
does the US government pay on an annual
basis just on paying its previous debts
in 2022 it was a lot 8.5 of all spending
went to paying interest on that debt the
concern is that so much money over time
will start going just towards the debt
that you may not be able to spend what
you want to spend on other issues here
are the other places the US spent money
in 2022 this biggest section here is all
Social Security
these sections Medicare and Medicaid
this third biggest section is the
military
then there's the Department of Education
most of this is student loans the cost
of Biden's potential student loan
forgiveness plan there's tax credits
like child credits Veterans Affairs and
nutritional services like Snap the rest
of this other category went to smaller
places like coronavirus relief the
Department of Transportation or Homeland
Security
Beyond Medicare Social Security interest
payments on the debt and the Pentagon
budget everything you think of in terms
of what the federal government does on
an annual basis is actually a small
minority of actual annual government
spending
in 2022 more than 20 percent of that
spending was funded by taking on debt
this is the total amount of debt built
up every year it's currently a little
over 30 trillion dollars and there's a
cap to how much this can be the infamous
debt ceiling debt ceiling debt ceiling
that limit is currently 31 trillion
dollars an amount that the treasury is
set to hit in June when that happens
they'll be unable to take on extra debt
through those Securities which means
there won't be enough cash to pay social
security benefits seniors won't get
their checks neither would members of
the military
and these debt holders wouldn't get
their interest payments that would
create all sorts of Financial and
economic problems because U.S treasuries
are viewed as kind of this Safe Haven
asset for the Global Financial system
there's this idea that if suddenly
investors thought well if I buy U.S
government debt I might not get my money
back that there could be a sell-off in
U.S government bonds and that would uh
raise interest rates across the world
economy it's up to Congress to pass a
bill that the president then signs to
raise this limit so that doesn't happen
both parties agree this chart should go
down but they disagree on how to do that
if you're trying to reduce the deficit
or eventually even reduce the debt it is
to either cut spending or to raise taxes
many Democrats want to raise taxes on
the rich and corporations I want to make
it clear
I'm going to raise some taxes
many of your billionaires out there
you're going to stop paying a three
percent
while Republicans largely want to see
spending cuts and they want those cuts
as a condition for raising the debt
ceiling Kevin McCarthy even promised to
do it as part of his deal to become
speaker the responsible debt limit
increase that puts us on a path towards
a healthier economy but Democrats want
just a clean race to the debt limit to
be able to pay for this spending
Congress already approved it is
something that should be happy that
should be done without conditions there
should be we should not be negotiating
around it so if there were Cuts where
might they come from cuts to Social
Security and Medicare seem to not be an
option Social Security Medicare is off
the off the books now right
we got unanimity
and not all Republicans support cuts to
the military I think there's there's
room for Savings in the military too
we've got to get spending under control
but we are not going to do it on the
backs of our troops which only leaves
these departments and discretionary
programs as places for cuts it's safe to
say that marginal Cuts while you know
something that may be worth considering
in various ways and whether it's a wise
use of resources to begin with are not
something necessarily something that's
going to make a major difference towards
reducing a deficit or you know balancing
the budget for example while Democrats
and Republicans May disagree how to do
that they both agree that the U.S can't
let the penny stop
foreign